[Music]
your outfit shows that you've really
evolved over the years because there's a
thing everybody knows about called
called throwback Thursday oh yeah you
can post pictures of yourself in your
early teens yeah and not too long ago
you zapped out this photo of yourself
where it looks like you're in a
breakfast club phase what were you
thinking what was happening there I was
thinking you know Judd Nelson will never
die that look will be here forever
we'll always be separated into these
social archetypes and yeah
if I don't fly my flag proud then no
one's ever gonna know my name I haven't
seen that movie in long enough to know
what you're talking about I honestly I
think I was yeah this is the point in my
life where I just I didn't care if you
didn't care and then without this
picture I don't know what's happening
here right well so you know sad it looks
like you just realized here you're
wearing here's what's funny is this
picture is actually about almost two
years before the previous picture so
this picture with me with those jeans
but this is me like really trying to fit
in with the kids in my neighborhood I'm
rocking the torn up cuffed bugle boys I
got some like you know Opie shirt with
the sleeves rolled up and I even got
Jordans on the card I'm trying yeah and
you got that it's got a coolest car I've
ever seen that is that was actually my
mother's car I learned to drive stick on
that car that's a sweet ride are you got
to learn to drive stick you do okay